[Musique]
c'était la façon de voir l'exercice
physique en 1971 il ne faut jamais
perdre de vue cette détermination cette
ténacité cette volonté qu'il faut pour
s'astreindre un régime de vie presque
des machines qui se sont montrés
inefficaces et d'autres qui sont devenus
les ancêtres des équipements actuels en
66 on a découvert que bouger au lieu
d'user le corps bouger c'était bon pour
le corps alors ça ça a été un peu une
révolution
[Musique]
et développer sa forme physique à un
prix notamment le prix de l'effort
la mise en forme c'est une bonne mais
heureusement que cette mode est arrivé
maintenant parce que je pense que
beaucoup de gens avaient besoin ou
tournant des années 80 la recherche de
la formule idéale a mener des artistes
connus à promouvoir la danse aérobique
comme claire pin Paris un disque qui est
une méthode de danse aérobique mais le
disque les gens vont pouvoir en faire
chez eux quand ils vont vouloir à
l'heure que ça va leur convenir puis
finalement ils n'ont pas à débourser des
montants pour des abonnements
Jane Fonda devient une gourou de
l'exercice mais sur 10 ou sur qu'à cette
vidéo les entraînements en solo ont leur
limite on pourrait faire la chose
complètement tout croche et puis avoir
des blessures donc et il manquait le
social
pendant des années les abonnements au
gymnase ont le vent dans les voies
surtout en début d'année avec les
habituelles résolutions des résolutions
qui finissent par s'essouffler janvier
c'est les parties de Noël le surplus de
poids les pantalons un peu serrés donc
c'est les résolutions de la nouvelle
année malheureusement ça se traduit
aussi par beaucoup d'abandon quelques
mois plus tard l'industrie de la mise en
forme veut donc faire en sorte que les
clients maintiennent leur motivation
elle la trouve beaucoup moins dans
l'idée d'honorer sa vieille résolution
du Nouvel An que dans le désir de rester
en bonne santé avec des parents qui
vieillissent des amis qui tombent
malades je me suis rendu compte que
c'était plus important je pouvais plus
me voir en photo je me détestais de la
danse aérobic à l'aquaforme les formules
se sont diversifiées au fil du temps les
uns aiment les nouveaux alors faut
trouver une nouvelle façon de donc les
Zumba de ce monde les bouquins
l'entraînement a ciel ouvert est devenu
une tendance lourde
c'est possible finalement et que ça peut
être très énergisant les mots de change
tout comme les motivations de ceux qui
veulent bouger
en faisant du spinner ou encore du
Crossfit après des autant les activités
aérobiques que les activités de
musculation faire de l'étirement étirer
les muscles qui ont été très contractés
avec le confinement et la pandémie il a
fallu se rabattre sur l'entraînement en
ligne pour notre kinésiologue la formule
idéale est aussi celle qui permet de
rester fidèle à sa résolution si c'est
un obligation qui s'ajoute par rapport à
la kyrielle d'obligation que j'ai je ne
veux pas je ne ferai pas ici à nouise
des pâtissiers Radio-Canada Montréal